welcome to this video playing Pasha from
the United States and I'm trying a
Sicilian here trying to get something
more aggressive in with Bishop g7 going
for the coop right shake variation
always leading to sharply interesting
yeah that's it's very similar to the
night off the differences i have not
played a 6 ok not sure if this is a
strength or weakness that i haven't
played a 6 yeah he tries to to do
something that wants to show that a 6 is
a useful maybe but maybe it's not making
much sense I never know maybe be five
even why not be five and 94 maybe I come
on let's let's play with those tactics
IAM no threatening Knight f3 here can I
can't you can be overlooked sometimes
White Rose I ok I am glad to free me I'm
just glad to get in a win yeah even had
such such a cheap trick after this this
losing streak I came what about the
objective merit of the position here it
seems to be ok yeah I thought so it
looks very active it looks very active
I'm also attacking here the computer
wants to play Bishop b5 which is not
really brilliant or man really brilliant
is a bit unfair I mean it looks like if
this is the one you need to play it's
not especially great for white
but this seems to be still okay okay the
computer now wants to take on B 3 and 0
and C 3 just trade everything off but
this is actually a good end game if we
look at this this is quite nice i also
have d 704 for the king and c3 is hard
to kill her if he do does that is this
coming that's quite nice for black i get
to get this porn at least so it seems
that like had an ok position but ok
Newcastle's it's very very helpful ok
thanks for watching